[Music]
working at Walmart is making me hate
being alive just found out I'm working
Black Friday at Walmart as a cashier
hope I don't die I only keep my job at
Walmart because it helps with all my
psychology and sociology classes
favorite part about working at Walmart
is finding stolen pregnancy boxes
working for Walmart has taught me one
thing people ask the dumbest questions
do you work here no I don't because I
totally wear khakis and navy blue to
pick up cute boys I love working at
Walmart you get to check out all the hot
moms and matures I work at Walmart and I
was printing some pictures off a flash
drive and they were down there pics I
was mortified I work at Walmart and tell
people who want to apply that they're
making a mistake I work at a Walmart and
don't snitch on thieves because I hate
the Walmart company everyone knows
you're the richest family in the world
you only pay us 8 dollars and 31 cents
an hour [ __ ] I work at Walmart and I
hate it
the best part of my job is getting paid
to poop tonight I only worked 4.5 hours
and went poop three times you're welcome
Sam Walton
[Music]